[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to the brand new podcast
are you garbage I am a ho stage Foley
sitting directly across from me is my
number one my co-host my sidekick my
side chick ladies and gentleman mr.
Kevin James Ryan hey what's up everybody
happy to be here I like how you welcomed
everybody back to the first episode
which i think is impossible I don't
believe I said welcome back it was very
cautious with that you did you fumbled
you fumbled the first pass I get it
though time is a flat circle happy to be
here happy to be here very nice Kevin
and of course sitting to our immediate
right is our inaugurate Orie guests here
are our new garbage
okay good friend of ours started on the
Philly comedy scene together he's up
here doing pretty good things okay now
falling behind not showing off good pal
of ours ladies and gentlemen mr. Quillan
finance hi everybody good to be here
thank you for having me on the first
episode it's an honor and even more than
that I just feel blessed to have fully
give us both backhanded compliment I
know on his intro my sidekick now you
only write bad he wrote that three weeks
ago this blog doing great but he's not
doing bad give it up for middle of the
road spider is stupid fat piece of [ __ ]
the meat part of the meaty part of the
curvy and okay talk to the host oh my
god yeah I wasn't talking to Kevin like
hahahaha we just met he's gotta get back
and return that cool new shirt he's got
off yeah to get out of here and play a
game of racquetball
it's squash is it hard with that haircut
is it hard to play squash and bully an
eighth grader yeah yeah I'd say buzz
your girl from life God where's your
tarantula Foley's buzzing and the
girlfriend
so listen gang this is our brand-new
podcast like I said it's called are you
gar
[ __ ] okay well we sit down with the
guests every week and determine if in
fact are they a piece of trash cuz yeah
so this is the my theory we're all
[ __ ] trashed it doesn't matter it has
to do with money or anything you know
cuz like he grew up like you you were
all kind of poor right wouldn't say poor
I was middle class the meaty part of the
curve for sure middle of showing off not
like I had I had a little my family had
a little bit of money at times because
but it was a very blue-collar so we were
like still [ __ ] trash we lived in
like a nice neighborhood but we were
like scars yeah there was there was a
big NASCAR feather was again on there
was a shed that was never finished in
the backyard yes your home was like new
construction yeah it's just always
always selling a McMansion outside
always warm we lived in a that was
always one poor family that lived in
that neighborhood art wasn't done oh
well like I had I mowed the lawn
everybody else had like a landscaping I
was out there with the John Deere you
know do you remember the kid growing up
word you could do anything in their
house the parents were like never
anybody just but it was always like
dirty you know I'm talking about
oh yeah we weed kids like that in the
neighborhood my mom used to wash my toys
in the dishwasher wash you in the dish
oh my gosh I poked its daddy
they dude they had like nine they kept
having kids cuz they weren't a girl yeah
I mean it was like God can you move to
China but if you're when you're a little
nap on there ya go to a friend's house
and be like oh man I don't want to eat
over like that yeah most a lot of really
I had one get free meal it was a free
meal
yeah do you have any I could take home
to my mother
yeah well you're the kid that used to
force himself going over the friend's
house to eat can I stay over my house is
a lot of parents hated your guts now as
a little kid you probably got along with
mom moms really well along with everyone
man my house was the house everyone came
over to play with to play at and what AJ
was unlike grade school well it was like
a couple weeks ago yeah yeah it was I
can Steve come over blame I do do you
remember when you would want to have a
sleep where you go you call and then go
can my mom talk to your mom
yeah for them to like plan I I loved it
because it was so exciting
someone ever do that hands off to other
people like my mom for some reason was
real weird about that [ __ ] she hated
yeah because she's got to clean the
trailer Terry put your beds away the fat
ones good friends coming over yeah she
leaned the wood panel she hated giving
all through high school she hated me
sleeping out that like friends house
like it was always a thing of like what
you don't want to stay here you don't
want to stay here with your family
that's that I was guilt way yeah and you
know what it was because I remember when
I was I was born in a place called
mountaintop all right it's [ __ ]
garbage for sure and my cousin's little
girl you dated in college my cousins
live next door but then they moved
that's another sign of garbage oh my god
yeah so listen so they moved and
kindergarten and this hot young couple
moved in this was I'm talking this is
early 80s all right these people were
attractive don't robux and [ __ ] playing
volleyball in the back she was smokin I
knew this in kindergarten all right but
he worked for Kellogg's so they had all
these little boxes of cereal all the
time everything you were 11 minis so I
would go over there all the time and
like how many of their dogs got killed
cos holy blamed it on Fido no but like
for some reason me and this woman like
really hit it off and like I would go
over there all the time and hangers
woman hit it all I'm telling you I think
you were molested Yeah right
she used to lure me Ovilus with tasty
treats and sugary sugary snacks if she
molested me I hope I don't wanted to be
blocked out she was looking Farrah
Fawcett that's a quarter off that day
yeah but I remember one time my mom like
screaming at me like yeah you're hanging
out with the [ __ ] hot 22 year olds at
[Laughter]
epistle that a couple of times talking
to your mom
yeah put your mom's [ __ ] on the phone
so what Kevin is saying the line is Ian
so what Kevin is saying what Kevin is
saying is that you know being garbage is
determined by by money your social class
it's just the kind of habits that you
develop well that you get from your
parents or that you your parents might
not be like I don't really think my
parents are trash but I know I'm trash
well my thing is and I would talk about
this about how we're all garbage but the
good thing about garbage is that you can
recycle so no matter how bad you are you
can always change a bit no I understand
for sure yeah yeah that's like something
do you think so you do think you're
garbage
well that's why I haven't my I'd shove
cans up my ass and puke up cardboard
Intercity eighth grade teacher I used to
be one oh my god wait you actually talk
yes I taught the inner city since I was
like [ __ ] in college right take it
easy Joe Brown
I am I what's the state Joe Clark I
truly when I was a teacher I thought it
was a joke Clark and Michelle Pfeiffer I
thought if I carried a bat and poor
leather jackets kids don't know what to
think where were you a teacher New York
City hold on wait hold on they'll hire
anybody I talk did you girls yeah you
went to NYU and graduated from NYU yeah
five years I took a victory lap wow I
didn't know that yeah talk about talk
about garbage I [ __ ] well hey didn't
even [ __ ] heeda heeda heeda left
college to follow fish on ice KITT talk
about garbage I had to take a semester
of all in completes because I was just
drinking alone all the time and then
told all my professors I was in rehab
and sold everything I had for Jesus man
I didn't know at the time that I was
having alcohol withdrawal so when I went
in the room I was just naturally shaking
so they like really took me yeah of
course yeah well yeah you're going by as
my I've since made amends with them
individually and everything but what I
had to do was my I had to take an extra
semester so I had to do one semester my
normal semester plus the old
semester work load plus work at the same
time student teach it was a [ __ ]
insane [ __ ] terrible
Plus being alcoholic it was all at least
it was fun it was alive I think we
answered the garbage question here my
bringing the next guest everyone hey and
thanks for stopping by your [ __ ]
train got the back door
I had an essay due and my last day
student teaching I the night before I
went out with friends and it was like
5:00 p.m. and that I was like this is my
last essay my end of it oh my god let's
do shots it's like well we just have a
beard I go no no let's do shots oh I got
around a shot heroin yeah and no one
wanted to do shots it was like Bob dayum
yeah so then I don't worry that guy I've
done that for sure and I was like okay
before this I say let me just take a
gravity bong hit and then I'll [ __ ]
clear my head yeah dude I woke up at
3:00 a.m. a [ __ ] mess how to do the
next morning funny I didn't know you had
it that bad
yeah [ __ ] nuts bro will you booze and
when you were an intern yes dude I was
stopped at the deli chugging a beer
puking in a trash can and then going in
and teaching Shakespeare real he was
[ __ ] nuts huh to be garbage
organizing I was garbage for very long
time
and I've done my due diligence to inform
against me yeah it's a nice little
script day god bless whole treatment on
that yeah that was his elevator pitch
that was a long [ __ ] elevator though
it's in 190th floor that I was a booze
bank in a shitty teacher podcast
this is are you garbage very funny so we
were I was like yeah I was I think it'll
be a great first guest one we have a
history
mmm you know everything like that and
plus he's [ __ ] trash you know I mean
oh no I'm on a bashful tribe yes and
then for the listener before we started
recording and you know filming this
Ian pulls out of a [ __ ] red bandanna
like the nerdiest the nerdiest blood
gang member I've ever seen in my life
and blows his nose in it and then
proceeds to wipe his face with no one
will you wash that dude you cannot be
under 80 and carry a [ __ ]
handkerchief my grandfather carried a
handkerchief L praise me so I carry a
handkerchief but my dad wore bandanas
grandfather had a handkerchief so let's
combine the two a bandana handkerchief
hang on raised by grandparents that's
knocking our slept in beds with adults I
was like Willy Wonka & the Chocolate
otally but speaking of bandanas when I I
was teaching in Brownsville and that's
garbage - right there speaking of damage
what kids would throw out bags of weed
on the desk big what do you think of
this Cali Kush I'm bi I think if I turn
around it's still there I'm going home
and smoking a bag of weed so I turn
around they take it you know it was like
to test me and then I you know it was
sweating I pulled out a red bandana in
this kids lying colors they were like
listen what's worse they were they were
like this is like 2006-2007 and this
this kid was like listen mr. fry dance I
like you you got to throw that bandana
way right now color was because it was
red and they were like the Crips yeah
man we're gonna kill you
and I was like I'm a teacher and he goes
they don't care if you're just dropping
oh yeah the gang members that you know
I've never been more scared in New York
City than going to and from the school
in Brownsville to teach I mean yeah I
got a man I mean one of my kids got one
of my every one of my kids got his cell
phone stolen and word got out that he
told insurance to get a new phone and
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and his
mom took him out of school and they
moved to Michigan how's the lacrosse
program yeah I mean kids would be on the
cell phone in class like this was a
school where you went to if you got
kicked out of me my brother had to get a
final credit you spend time in juvenile
detention whatever so kids would be in
class on the cell phone talking about
like different guns I own and I'd just
be like guys on the board please I'm mr.
Fayden I mean I really had to learn
about like choosing the fires to put out
yeah you know you know which which which
battles to take but then you know it was
great I were just [ __ ] drink a 40 on
the way home and forget about it and
then you move to Philly and started
doing comedy
I'm mm I moved to Delaware but bragging
I started doing comedy in Philly and
moving back to Delaware yes that's where
you grew up
yes Wilmington I left at 18 move back
laughter in 2003
you leave at 18 your moves move like
very Springsteen asked like you know you
put your guitar and your back and here's
a turn in the road I'm gonna be somebody
it was it was like and I miss all DuPont
Factory in my rearview gonna be an
alcoholic teacher Brooklyn uh-oh you ma
I'll be somebody I'm gonna go drink a 40
and steal weed from adolescents why get
a bit when there's a curb with a
building pillow but yeah that was i I
left at 18 and I was [ __ ] wild
because I'd never been away from home
you know you think you took it while you
adjusted quite well yeah it was it was
[ __ ] rough roses now do you think
you're garbage uh yeah but I work on it
every day to not be hey you know I I
fully am aware that I've III wasn't
raised to be garbage but at a certain
point because of external yes certain
time that you realize your garbage and
in getting to know that child that was
not ever meant to be garbage I've gotten
rid of the garbage in through therapy
I've taken out the pieces put them on
the ground inspected and decided to
throw this out keep this whatever and so
I've really worked hard to recycle my
garbage and not be that piece of [ __ ]
well see I think I think I was a piece
of [ __ ] as a coping mechanism I think
some things some garbage things are good
or home like what in a flow we'll get
into when we play the game just
questions about when you're six and your
neighbor [ __ ] you for I don't think
it's I don't think it's totally things
that you need to be ashamed of I mean I
don't know what you were doing when when
you're when your last garbage and you
did when Raschi when you're an active
addiction do the --have in a way that
you never thought you would to get what
you need to get to be well oh sure and
so like you just do things that you're
like I can't and then that would keep me
acting in a garbage way because I would
act out and do something shameful then I
would drink to make the shame go away
and then I'd feel such shame I'd have to
do a shameful thing again to make that
go and it was just heated cycles just a
downhill a [ __ ] shame cycle that you
got to get yourself out of you know
sounds like a good time going yeah that
being a data side yes what's the last
last thing that was garbage like example
I thought today I did something that was
pretty trashy I really had to poop but I
was hungry so I was eating no not on the
toilet no I don't know
Willard I've drank in the shower I've
stroked different dude way that are
insane with his don't quote again I'm
just saying that I had to go but I kept
sitting there eating eating what I had
to get a fat thing I don't know that's
really [ __ ] alright that's a fat
piece of [ __ ] that's like I want to
finish this yeah that's like the the bag
of fat from Fight Club the table I
didn't name a thing I've done it
name a thing I guarantee I've done it
sex what a dog your clothes that oh yeah
it's a cat oh that's oh you have a dog
too and I kiss him on the lips yeah now
you get a little weird with those
animals I love animals
no but I just kissing on my dog when I
was I'm not with my mouth but just like
that's it I'm leaving Delaware one more
for the road like that
but I wish it was a girl that's pretty
good but I never had sex with an animal
what I did something recently I was it
uh we should play garbage bingo with me
and I guarantee we'll hit all the
[ __ ] numbers yeah just five five
things get called you got it yeah I I
did a thing you know money's tight a
little bit you know when I'm not I'm not
rolling in the dough over here so I was
that I was at a club on the road and
Kevin's getting married you know I'm
getting married it's two days you're
getting married in two days Ian shut the
[ __ ] up in City Hall trash that's the
word garbage the ceremony's not in two
days
yeah Friday rule yeah Friday with
everyone invited yeah small though it's
very small no we all got screwed you
invite any of us don't dynamited I know
what you're fishing for dude can I tell
you a thing about invitations to a
wedding so talking about being garbage
I've had a tendency to like literally
isolate and like extract myself from
like friends and I mean I've done it
with you guys have you ever gone to a
wedding and not giving a gift oh yeah
yeah yeah do you nerd I so
I did I did it to somebody that's like
that's like a family friend and I hadn't
seen him in like 20 years
and I saw him because my aunt passed
away he came to the funeral and I got a
real strong feeling he in over it now
yeah you know I mean just like you know
that I showed up I danced I got sauced
up I made everyone have a fun time
that's a better gift today yeah
Richfield ham that's what a garbage
person tells him you know my 25 bucks
was out there man a paper pocket yeah
moving and shaking I already shift I
took I took my buddy and his wife out to
the Cheesecake Factory
oh I never had money what do you want
that's a [ __ ] you know you got they
probably hate it yeah they improv I
hated that gift Cheesecake Factory is
delicious I've never given a gift it's
always always scared Oh
police mom asked me where I was
registered I thought um JG Wentworth
it's my money and I need it now
oh my ship that [ __ ] cash Rena Center
that's not registered No
why are you doing this so fast he's not
doing his face he's just got engaged
three weeks yeah yeah yeah yeah the day
Khan died you [ __ ] did you laughter
yeah well I dude I gotta tell you so I
um you know for whatever reason and I
figured out you know I've had massive
abandonment issues so I'll get close and
then I leave so you don't have a chance
to leave me know what I mean yeah and I
spend a lot of time like isolating
whatever and you know I'm very much like
a lone wolf and I just have to accept it
whatever but I was killed Billy oh so
there I am staring at a noose I'm not
sure what to do but you know I figured
the Cheesecake Factory dates next week
I'll take Billy and Jamie out
you know you've been too hard on
yourself I've had a lot of friends
who've been there for me and I've chosen
not to be in their lives whatever so
this guy that you know best friend lived
with him on and off since we were like
18 whenever I kind of went I we just you
know and when you get involved in comedy
you kind of lose and everybody get
everybody get on out so I
I'm living with two of our other best
friends we lived together in college we
lived together after college right so
they're talking about his wedding and
they're like oh yeah well the save the
date is whatever Oh actually the the
invitation you know whatever and I'm
kind of listening through the weeks and
then like they're like yeah I'm getting
ready for the wedding next weekend I'm
like huh
so I text my go hey man I know our mail
systems messed up sometimes buddy
you stink I did hey I know the words and
I hit him up and go he goes you know I
didn't want to have this conversation
but it's a small wedding and we also
haven't been closed state of Latin
America but it's receive mine I did not
take the social cue and I had such
hubris
well the mails messed up me the whole
thing in Syria hey Gary its Ian listen I
understand that you can't afford to send
out invites and you're probably calling
people and that's [ __ ] that's that a
Garvin that's that's good that's a
garbage move yeah I couldn't stop that
on so many levels but it yeah you just
put me through all the lies you get the
intro am I not invited to this wedding
it mark me now for the chicken and no
gift but I'll tell you all right I'm
talking to him about it
we have my old blender we'd like to talk
about our friendship and everything and
every spot it's like oh that makes good
in the end you know right near that
buffet [ __ ] move yeah so this is
someone I met this you know comedy club
I'm on the road and this is this guy do
you
I think about this two or three times a
day and I didn't have and the you know
so obviously you know I you know I was
featuring so it's like you're not making
a whole bunch of money you know so it's
like and you know the club takes scary
and everything but you always gotta
always got a tip off the staff very you
know and they were they were super nice
it was super good everything was great
you know so the first night I hit him
you know next night too I always want to
do it on
I always do it the night out the night I
used to do at the end of the weekend
there's some where they turn over and
then you get there on Saturday you're
like where's Gary they're like oh he's
all what are you doing and he hates sure
it depends when I get something if I'm
like drinking or if I get dinner
sometimes I just get like two diet cokes
or whatever so it depends but you know
typically if I like get a meal I give
you what I would have got that take
Carrie at the end of the weekend [ __ ]
come on well seven that's when you get
paid I used to do that but now I do i do
i do night of yeah but I only get
coffees yeah so it's like you shouldn't
be really you don't get a hot meal oh I
always well yeah I'm in like drink wise
yeah yeah cuz it drinks your rack up
they driver yeah yeah so I don't think I
don't think I ate but I might had like a
couple diet cokes or whatever I'm sorry
I know this buddy killed I'm a big
tipper I'm a good tipper I always say
I'm a good tipper I stand by being all
right there let this let it be known
people who are good David I'm sweating
right now
Kevin Kippy James Ryan is a good time
yeah I would like to I shade that I am a
good tipper and but I didn't have any
cash on me right and I'm like oh I'll
get paid some whatever so but then this
guy so I think I get served or what I
did eat I did eat I think I got fries so
then he serves me the fries so this guy
comes up he takes the fries and then a
guy comes up next to me and orders a
beer and but then whatever the exchange
of it is he left a 20 in front of me
who's this guy just a guy buying a drink
at the mall pretend it was you I didn't
pretend it was anything they say was
this oh my god I'm not keeping the club
vague but it was I was on the road who
was on the road six years ago okay was
in years ago my hips I used to get a
little into the club and take him home
for dinner
you should do what I have been feeling
you've done that he's more than a couple
of years ago I I used to take extra
meals from the club and take him home
for dinner the next night so he goes so
he just granted was a 20 so he just
grabs the 20 and I'm not where I got my
phone after whatever him going over
notes getting ready for the show he goes
thank you so much man that means a lot
late and I was like what about them do
they ever ask about the beer he paid for
the beer they like say with it say was
five dollars with the beer the guy gave
him a five the guy wins this guy this
guy shot
that's what I'm saying he probably
whacked them off another 20 so he good
he grabs the 20 was thanks a lot me and
I wasn't really paying and then you know
I swear to God I didn't know something
he walked away and I'm like oh he
thought I left that [ __ ] 20 but also
no I ain't got no cash on me
so hold things I'm like I wouldn't have
liked it or anything so then I go
alright so that I'm like I'm like I'll
make it right I just don't have the
courage to make it right at the moment
you know like in my head I'm like I
don't know what the [ __ ] to say I
already he's gonna think I tried to pawn
it off like it's mine and then the he
must have went and told the other guy
cuz the other guy came up thanks a lot
for that by the way Oh buddy I'm in it I
can't so it's just yeah man and I just
left with my head between my legs good
kids like a real big piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tipped man I did it we got on that I
tipped on the first night this was the
second night so not only did I surf you
got paid you didn't go back and say hey
by the way I already lied I mean you
want to hear you got a key you gonna
[ __ ] kill all the witnesses you know
what I mean ah [ __ ] tipping story I'm
not proud of that have you ever worked
your restaurants you you yeah you
probably still do he's a waitress gotta
get to the Cheesecake Factory yeah but
from doing that for so long
I have them like ultra-sensitive another
yeah yes always I always tip about
always of course you know a clubs always
at that one time you know and except for
that one time yeah dude I I was working
at a restaurant and you know the
stereotype about certain types of people
that don't tip and we have a lot of them
that are friends Australian team in
Philly you know you know that's a that's
a that's a term in the industry they say
Canadians I know but I go go to take the
thing and I look and I see on the credit
slip they just didn't put anything for
tip and signed it and I was like a new
waiter and I was wrote it in what the
[ __ ] I was like are you kidding me or a
hero like these and my inner racism
started going I was like I [ __ ] knew
it I [ __ ] knew it and then I go to
chase them down the street and I'm like
you didn't [ __ ] leave me a tip then
go take the receipt out and I take it
out and it's all cash tip [ __ ] I'm a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] me
and you know it was I just felt so but
sometimes I didn't know how I've seen
that stereotype just proven of course
multiple of course yeah I had so this
but I do a club in st. Louis and you'll
see you proven see the staff also really
go along with it tell ya that is true I
worked at the dowels barbecue in Times
Square for a little while shot yeah what
was that life ain't no money to pay his
bill oh my god was it like a mace video
from 97 it was brutal that's the place
where they put they have like the frozen
no no money no to basic they stick the
beer or like a little bottle and yeah
margarita
that's Garvin how did you remember the
story in Chelsea about like that gay
hate crime some guy threw a chair at a
gay guy in the Chelsea Del's BB q
where'd that come from
I was in Dallas barbecue yeah yeah so
what happened was it a war zone yeah it
was terrible oh I do but like I'll do I
do respect a garbage move that have a
give that you telling that thing there
was a restaurant in Center City
Philadelphia when I was working and I
went in for lunch and I got like chicken
fingers and like you know a soda or
something
I think chicken fingers and Diet Coke
kinda gathers to crack how the chicken
finger I'll take the chicken fingers
platter please I'm a platter man so I
substitute the [ __ ] I [ __ ] it up I was
gonna say coleslaw for more substitutes
or fries for more chicken fingers dude
that jerk for a better punch so I so
then I wrote out let's just say the tip
was nine dollars right I'm making this
number up it was nine dollars the tip
was and I only had a hundred bucks in my
council I was like I swipe my card it
was tan the whole whole bill should have
been 20 and then I left the tip I left
the thing I left the other receipt as
well you know how they give you the
merchant copy and the shore so when I
left the other one customer copy I left
that as well and I know I haven't done
it since so he [ __ ] made it
the total he made the total $100
completely cleared out my bank account
to zero like I woke up the next morning
go back there went back there they
closed that night for good
it was his last hurrah swear to God
walked up [ __ ] doors boarded up
clothes for out of business
you [ __ ] got me a pretty good I got
got I can't help somebody move I got got
- one time I was on acid and I won't get
a cheeseburger in the East Village and
it was like the world's best
cheeseburger and so then I was eating it
I was like a dream of cheeseburgers
eating me this is not the best
cheeseburger this is a moment in time
you stand up for yourself make it so I
went got my money back through the
cheese Naha and I convinced myself on my
acid trip did I I started a new me one
is except for himself nope you're
garbage
yeah oh dude when I was drinking I used
to do a thing where I would go up and
say that I'd stand at the bar and here
you go I put on my tab Ryan and then
you'd piggyback on that well I would go
up to the guy and be like hey I had that
same shirt Wow and make a big deal MB I
can I get you a drink he'd be like okay
and then I go to the bar and be like hey
I keep put this on the Ryan tab and I
get a couple drinks and I go up and give
him one I just [ __ ] walk away that's
not terrible that's a that's a hasty
move but that's smart at least that's
like the old seabass said put it on
where do you think I learned yeah got
some Twizzlers magazine what happened
you've caught up with me down to the you
know down the road
[ __ ] [ __ ] I learned it that's
great yeah and sea bass for dance aha
all right let's get into the game here
gang alright so we're gonna ask you 15
to 20 questions okay now they're this
conversation starters alright nothing
too serious
yeah I know how my kids work just to
kind of determine you know what we're
working with here as we know ian is a
stand-up comedian here in New York City
he's a regular guest on the the you up
radio show with Nikki Glaser on Sirius
XM and he's out on tour right now with
mr. Dave Attell that's right but we have
to fill out that's awesome are you
garbage bumping mics
what are you garbage I mean we've
already talked about it yes the level of
how garbage you are Oh on these
situations yeah just yeah yeah yeah
let's find how you grew up type stuff
because I read some reason this weekend
I would
was I went home for the weekend and my
parents and I started talking about
something when I was a kid and I
realized how much garbage I am you know
our primary source of heat when I was a
kid
mm-hmm was a coal stove I don't even
know what that is that's amazing
what is that that's amazing like like
you couldn't afford it like change no we
could it's just that was like the thing
we liked it oh dude that's how your poor
parents told you nobody likes that my
char would pull up every every every
couple of weeks and it would give you
coal
it would poor little things a coal into
a coal bin and me and my brother would
have to bring the coal inside it seems
right yeah you gotta seem trash that
seems rustic and with a cabin heater but
no you'd pour it into a coal stove and
you wouldn't know what any of this
sounds like [ __ ] home on the you know
I don't know what any of us ticking nice
like that would happen in this town
called mountaintop this was in blue bell
pennsylvania my i really live next to
the super version in Center City
Philadelphia I realized I was trash when
my favorite memories as a kid were going
to the dump loading up the truck
throwing [ __ ] in the dump the cherry
island dump you know what else was a big
one for me when I realized was we would
go trash picking why yeah we like drive
around with my step definitely take a
bike that you would see or a what a lamp
or something I don't know he just
stealing people's garages you know where
people keep their trash the safe under
the bed garage hopping oh yeah
permanent records from garage oh dude
you used to go out at night and if they
left a garage throw in and steal beer
and yeah so go to the garage freezer and
steal beer now you get [ __ ] murder
you can't do that garage Fitz Kevin and
I are big fans
hey dude yeah oh garage fridge oh right
rich do when someone now we could they
were one way rich people get a college
boy dude when when [ __ ] uh you were
at someone's house and you heard go to
the fridge in the garage yeah I had an
ice cream Aaron's had all this stuff in
the jar full of oil
ya know homemade coughs arrows next to
it wait what who jars full of oil with
like the the peppers in yeah yeah
like ours have like [ __ ] ice pops and
sodas and Capri Suns and [ __ ] like that
dunkaroos my [ __ ] homemade canned
peaches and you had that steak from five
years ago things like a [ __ ] dry ice
in their [ __ ] weapon yeah all right
so as everybody knows whatever you said
here on the podcast ian is from
Wilmington Delaware
it's Wilmington proper five minutes
outside of it's a moment improper find a
shopping center just a couple of basic
questions yeah what was the grocery
store that you went to when you were a
kid was the Acme Acme good knit on the
road meaning part of the curve yeah
Acme's ain't bad name of your dentist
and or pediatrician when you were a kid
dr. Eng was he also in the same shopping
channel and doctor was he in the Acme I
forget who what doctor next to the deli
counter his name was like dr. de Santos
or just Santo or something sounds like a
DJ welcome back to the doctor to send
her a wedding you didn't get invited to
yeah you got choo choo choo chicken pox
doctor dr. de Santo item allergic
reaction to seek lor and my body broke
out in hives and I was almost paralyzed
like what's that so speak or it's some
medication I don't know in the room and
every time I was touched I would scream
I was in such pain and he was like you
know he won't lay down and my dad was in
the room he's like he's in pain
don't touch him like that and he goes
well he's not cooperating and he pushed
me down I screamed my dad took I'm gonna
push him out the walls like don't ever
[ __ ] touch my son like that one time
I got in a fight on him on you know that
thing that you stand that that
playground toy yeah right
me and a kid got in a fight on they
don't have those anymore I don't matter
at all yeah it's free you [ __ ] mental
nobody any kid gotta fight on that about
the Eagles and my dad's a lot of Eagle
my my dad stopped it and put us both on
the ground so we could fight in a safer
and as [ __ ] trash yeah that's my dad
would do the same thing
yeah I kept me what he got alright um
let's see let's see sorry has anyone in
your family ever owned a waterbed that
is [ __ ] I owed one I had to I used to
sleep there was it hated all mine was
heated and I was in a single lamp it was
yes and have you got an ant tiny your
[ __ ] shoe is tiny and she lady was a
truck tiny who was single and had her
own tiny it was just gettin a head tiny
who lived next door to my aunt dolly
anytime relatives are that close it's
[ __ ] tree yeah and aunt dolly also
had a room where aunt sis lives Delaware
baby not one of them had a real name in
that whole story do you know what's
really trashy dude have you did you then
aunt dolly had an above-ground pool
continue he's got a semi above-ground
pool which is even more trash it's like
dug two feet and all that my mija my
parents build a deck around it so you
can jump right in he thinks it's the
coolest thing in the world it is [ __ ]
bolster that's what crashed you're
justifying the garbage nest there just
admit we had to take turns on the one
lawn chair to get a suntan
that's did you grow up near our quarry
no okay
that's pretty good but but I was 10
minutes away from a coal like oil plant
like a bunch of power plants yeah sure
have you ever had a plane to the
forehead more questions have you ever
owned a guinea pig no never
a snake never a hermit crab yes all
right thank God yeah yeah I used to
thunk them off the cage you'd gain their
trust a little bit I don't know Harriman
have you or any member of your family
ever traveled to another state or
another town with the express purpose of
going to a buffet yes my took Lancaster
Pennsylvania my grandparents made
friends with the Amish
and I've had I had two Thanksgivings
with a straight-up Amish family where we
shot the turkey OH
you shot it yes and I would walk around
barefoot with them and we're playing
closed so that they would feel more
comfortable because it we're all black
and I'd shovel them Anor yeah
Jesus yep and I if I dance yeah anyone
in your family play scratch off lottery
tickets
yes I had an uncle that ran numbers
that's pretty classy numbers numbers
that's uh that's a respectable job yeah
growing up did your family have any
roommates we uh we had a minor league
baseball players stay yes stay at your
house one day I swear your momma sure
does love your baseball boy one day I
swear to God I made a joke on Twitter
that was like I loved Ghostbusters so
much I wonder if I was molested when I
watched it immediately this guy didn't
talk to in years
hey we should hang out sometime job yeah
I kind of think I was molested too and
blah no but I kind of have an aversion
to baseball now and baseball players
Kippy there currently any ketchup
packets in your fridge soy sauce packets
it doesn't that's on the fence I collect
chopsticks yeah that's normal
nobody really keeps a big jar of soy
sauce right well I do because I have
Asian roommates here I gotta be
progressive I got an Asian girlfriend we
got the best stuff okay what is that
what he trying to prove me wrong here I
don't know what about um who used to
babysit you you were a kid I had a
[ __ ] cast a character because we we
had a woman that was that was mentally
challenged up that babysit well let me
tell you something we [ __ ] tortured
this poor one's easy
we used to would send us to bed we would
wait like an hour like a full hour and
then sneak back downstairs why she was
all by herself watching TV and sneak up
into the chair behind her and just
[ __ ] yank to recline her back so she
would fall which screen does we just
would yell moonride I wasn't actually
called we called it a moon rod because
we'd give Doreen correctly a moon right
Doreen Doreen correct hole Doreen
me and serie going out oh my I left 24
pizza moonrise either Henry all that
Rita hurt Doreen and hide the sharp
object so you know was crazy is that
like after a little while they hired
another one that would come with her and
she was also mentally checked they're
the only two people who lived in mood
what do you talk about on top forever
the [ __ ] you did we had one so my buddy
had one growing up in Lake his parents
would go out and this girl would woman I
don't know what she was from the wrong
side of the tracks and Bensalem
Pennsylvania bad like babysitters are
from the wrong yeah well there's no
there's no [ __ ] you know Scott rogue
scholars going out for babysitting jobs
so she would let it we were twelve
thirteen and she would let us watch porn
and now looking back I like the first
wait how is she like twenties third she
happy no no the first time we can watch
someone we get home we were leaving the
Shamy mom I dropped me off waiting
this is [ __ ] wait really yeah dude
that you were one step mother being
molested I wasn't I wasn't my friend so
like I was with my friends and if you're
13 and she's 20 that's not she was like
that's a funny glitch while she was late
20 she shouldn't have been
she shouldn't have oh no all right you
want to go away I was obviously she I
was gonna be in a position for her to
molest me but you want to talk garbage
you want to talk garbage the first
cigarette I ever smoked was my
babysitter ah that's pretty bad
and what was it was bland and my mom's
very true box remember those the grey
box the cigarettes now if I behaved well
with my stepdads family my mom would let
me smoke cigarettes how old are you 60
90 that's still a 96 that's still mom
would let you smoke I was such a bad mom
let you have a cigarette if you're good
I'll let you have a cigarette
I'll give you one of my palm cigarette
if you behavior says your mom have a
cigarette purse like a little cases of
their little red poison snaps open oh
they used to put their cigarettes image
to play with that all the time
but they would just I I didn't have a
red purse I just had red marks where
they put the cigarettes out on me have
you any way have you ever owned a
required a timeshare have you ever sold
timeshare no but I sold free
construction estimates I I did that too
are you currently did you work for uh
who was it well absolute shame on a
second here
are you a name of your friend we're
currently interested that's a good piece
of business right there H well either
yet by the end of the show you're like
they gave me a pen it's fiscally
irresponsible not to do it because when
we were in AC last together there was a
dude in the five-and-dime store that had
his own little stand that was even
pitching them dude he had been doing
math for like a week what the polo shirt
on not good is there still a VCR at your
mom's house yes whoa yeah go Foley when
you were here okay here you go is your
belly button in any er now Dee because
if it's an Audi uh-huh but I bet you
were the kind of kid that had an Audi
when you were a kid you seemed like you
were a little slug a little skinny piece
skinny kid that was like muscular my
uncle said that I look like a bleached
Rwandan
real progressive guy remember the the
Rwandan genocide that's the other that
works for the Obama campaign now he's
the one that blew his head off a couple
years ago he ran out of his government
Vietnam anybody go postal in your back
have you ever used the barbecue in a
public park to cookout yes I don't drive
a car these are family dinners at a rest
up that's which woman Smyrna Delaware
murder
I know that was a central location for
us to meet that's a little dick that was
a restaurant it had like a park yeah he
said the same thing about his SMI
above-ground in
indoor/outdoor memories I'm not saying
they're not it's your best with what you
got of course and I'd rather have that
than a [ __ ] I don't even know what
rich people do for whatever are you like
we went to the shore we want to all
pitch in and rent like a condo together
you know seven people free I hold on a
trailer condo was it near a beach or
anything it was on the boardwalk or just
like in another part of your town no is
it the hidden Rehoboth Beach brah hope
yeah we'd all come we'd all crammed into
a condo together first week of August my
dad's mom had a trailer down and like
Luis he and I would go down there we fix
things up at the trailer it was the best
you know I almost I loved it when my
father will we moved to Philadelphia to
the suburbs in Philadelphia which I
believe changed us from becoming
massively can you want garbage you would
have been a squirrel hunter or something
oh I can't imagine what I can't hang out
I gotta I gotta go hunt for beaver pills
crackers yeah so that's when I got a
line there in April that's right I grew
up in wilkes-barre why we would have
stayed up there I said of Hill comes
gonna move yeah I suppose the date a
girl that lived in a halfway house in
wilkes-barre yeah I used to go up and
visit her so we moved out of there when
I was in fourth grade I moved out I told
her I loved her in a Denny's what that's
garbage either way no tell them somebody
that lives in a yeah but yeah been to a
Denny's recently still a top-shelf
operation amazing oh my god you look
like you were at a Denny's today yes Sam
you look like you are a dentist but if
we didn't stay if we stayed in
wilkes-barre and didn't move to the
suburbs of Philadelphia which is a nice
area
I God knows what I'd be doing right now
you probably be better off yeah you'd be
a property owner for sure yeah dude you
probably have a family be content no you
wouldn't have to get what I asked is it
make you feel better you want to be
wearing Big Pun sweatshirt either yeah
would you weren't a letter restaurant a
player I just eat a lot
you [ __ ] stink I have a better
colored tongue that thing why I love
saying a cow's tongue like a Shiba inus
tongue this is my friend Japanese dog
hates phony everybody don't forget to
rate review all this drive allows me to
work every day just sits waiting for me
to get help
I practice kissing them one time one
time so funny this is the best yeah I
love it
have you have you ever been to a wedding
at a VFW no I have I've been to a couple
let me tell you something my job and
used to play there you know what oddly
goes good together mashed potatoes and
meatballs go phenomenal together that's
always what they have their mashed
potatoes meatballs they have some kind
of rosewood you've catered the [ __ ]
thing fried chicken and a little
coleslaw how do you feel about coals
I have played a VFW hall if you like
coleslaw awesome
I have played a VF Nicole saw was one of
my favorites I have played a VFW hall
yeah me too it I was also a place where
they had like a funeral and they were
half day two funerals a week before
funeral the week after and they just
didn't change anything because I just
turn Oh God hold on back what was the
name of your band sock full of pennies
that's not de NN y Z full of trash this
is one this is one I think it's a it's a
very common do you pee in the pool I
know but I pee in public I pain the
point I mean I pee outside oh sure yeah
I'd be on the street I'd be between cars
yeah yeah you know I've [ __ ] in a bag on
on Landsdowne Street in Boston how do
you feel about the Fast and the Furious
franchise I've never seen it they're
pretty good not that too bad I've never
seen it
alright I got one more pick one yeah you
got Applebee's Fridays or Olive Garden
Olive Garden
all day wait I gotta get Friday s
meeting you went though Fridays in
Altoona Pennsylvania
Oh buddy that was a game-changer I don't
know if they got a new head chef or what
they're doing
but it ain't bad I'm telling if you go
to one of those casual dining
establishments in small towns where
there's not like a like a like a like a
real restaurant they are [ __ ] on pack
yeah they are on [ __ ] point I went to
a Denny's in Altoona with cotton and it
was like you spent a lot of [ __ ] time
in Altoona Pennsylvania
it looks like LT looks like hey I'm
doing a Altoona he had some bad Altoona
anyway
that's his nice restaurant Denny's real
close yeah she talked on you loved him
good had a Michelin star so that's more
the story is your [ __ ] garbage we
know that going in but I'm I'm a lovable
garbage I go out I'm a lovable garbage
can we all are that's not the point is
yes everybody's [ __ ] trash and it's
funny to Dan to jump back into your life
to admit it because to ever think that
you're not is lying of course of course
even if anyone that tries to say that
they're yeah but I feel like rich
people's garbage is more like
manipulative behaviors in a way like our
garbage was a lot of physical
circumstantial choice but I feel like
rich people's garbage is like oh I you
know spread rumors about so or so ya
know but they still do like rich people
who really work with their family to
like they don't like they're not like as
like loving with each other yeah and and
like not as loving with each other but
like they'll be like a they'll go out to
dinner and they'll split to check or
something weird like that I don't know I
I just say like give me a park
give me a bench and give me a grill
that's nailed to the ground and I'll
give you a good child no for sure I get
you come wider league baseball players
thrown in there too huh just don't make
it make sure we don't watch ghostbusters
listen gang this is our brand new
podcast are you garbage we want to tell
you to rate review and subscribe on
iTunes it'll be on YouTube on on Spotify
anywhere you listen to podcast but
especially iTunes please rate review
leave 5 stars
and yeah tell a friend we appreciate it
and can I tell you to follow me on
Instagram oh [ __ ] anything you want but
I animal like iPhone but I animal I in
finance calm for all my dates I got a
lot of fun stuff coming up and yeah baby
I'm going on tour it's gonna be a lot of
fun and I couldn't be happier that you
guys asked me to do this yeah buddy
thank you so my oldest friends in comedy
I love you both so much I gotta tell you
he vetoed it right away though
well he's not acting like it but almost
funny enough phone calls every day hey
so here's a question here's a time here
I want to make sure you show up oh my
god of course I would but it all worked
out the experiment I thought was that
was pretty good yeah I'm so happy I
could be a part of it thank you guys so
much I love you both
thank you I want to make sure
everybody's subscribe on all these place
we got it anxious alright we need this
can't be what do you got that's it Kevin
Ryan comedy comm on all social media
it's at Cameron comedy Twitter Facebook
anything coming up all my dates are yeah
I have I'll be an AC Connecticut couple
shows in Connecticut yeah so just go to
Kevin ranked Omnicom very nice I got a
couple of things I just want everybody
to keep an eye out for the new season of
the last øg øg go to the wrap party oh
that's right cool you got your cool
jacket aside ooh big Caesar yeah Tracy
I'm just like you keep an eye out for
the wall you and I have a movie coming
out in the spring called the outside
story with Brian Tyree Henry it's an
awesome movie yes keep an eye out for it
and we'll be back next week with a brand
new episode and a brand new guest are
you garbage see ya thanks guys